[Music]
hey kids it's me Kevin Smith here that
hum out there the hum of activity man
that's life just beyond the screen we're
at the Fillmore in Detroit 1300 people
plus out there ready to watch clerks
three man we've been on the convenience
tour uh for this is show 27 tonight so
we're now past the halfway mark uh we're
you know we're closing in on the end of
the tour which is kind of sad we still
have 23 more shows to go but the shows
that happened before this were
absolutely magical
um not only have the audience has been
great but we've been meeting people from
that Kevin Smith Club in advance of the
screening every night we do a little
meet and greet and we've met some fast
people to say the least and done some
very cool things are you curious what's
been going on for the last few weeks
while we've been on tour well here's a
little taste of what you missed because
this just in this ridiculously large
prop looking joint
is a gift and normally when you get a
gift like this it's decoration
this is a bat filled with actual
weed yes yes weed banana runs really
well we don't know where the weed came
from but we're just saying you might
know a thing or two about it I do I do
yeah good good Lord man this is such a
gigantic joint tell the story why uh the
last time I saw you in Denver I had
given you the biggest joint that they
had in Denver so I figured you're in my
home state I might as well one up myself
and give you the biggest one that they
have to offer this is the biggest one in
the [ __ ] world man this is a
challenge cone as seen in Jay and zombob
uh and by being used by Jane sound Bob
in clerks three
um I will I got
about 38 hours to smoke this [ __ ] down
before I head to Montreal they will not
let me take this on the plane and [ __ ]
but I will get to the bottom of it I'm
going to make you present it to me
tonight on stage uh so Aaron last time I
was here was 2019 perhaps for the show
come on up
um Aaron presented me with a joint while
I was here
and as a traveler of the green you
appreciate that you know somebody who's
looking out for himself and it was a
joint that was this big
[Music]
back then he gave me the biggest joint
I've ever had in Michigan and it was
this big tonight ladies and gentlemen
Aaron outdid himself
show him that Joy
is it real oh yeah 100 percent
what is it tell them what it is banana
runs
how long do you think it would take me
to finish this
I'm not sure man
I have basically I have tonight here in
town and then I have tomorrow in Detroit
then I have to get on a plane to
Montreal so that gives me about 36 hours
to burn this down and I promise you I
will do that very thing give it up for
Aaron and his Wonder joint
um happy to be here in the nation's
capital ladies and gentlemen um your
nation not mine
um
the uh uh just a quick story though I
you know we got here a little early uh
and uh but not early enough to like go
to the hotel and stuff so they got like
showers backstage and stuff so we just
crashed here when we got here and so I
had a couple hours and I I try to walk
every day about three four miles and
stuff so I was like [ __ ] it I'm gonna go
walk around [ __ ] campus and [ __ ] like
that there's like athletic fields I
could go walk around those all of them
locked and under key and [ __ ] like that
you know they don't want anybody on
those [ __ ] Fields they're real
serious so I just started walking around
campus doing circles and [ __ ] like that
and you know people would pass some
people would beep and whatnot
um as I was walking there was one uh guy
older dude and looked like he worked at
the the college or something like that
he was like hey it's you what are you
doing here
and I was like Oh I thought you know I'm
walking I'm trying to you know a heart
attack a few years ago so I'm trying oh
what are you doing here at the college
and I was like oh I'm gonna do a show
tonight he's like I didn't hear nothing
about it and that didn't make me feel
confident at all
this man worked at the campus for
Christ's sakes
I was like yeah we're over at uh the
Algonquin doing a thing he's like all
right I'll have to check it out I'm a
huge fan and I was like well thank you
very much he's like I was so sad when
they canceled Corner Gas
[Applause]
thanks
I didn't have the [ __ ] heart to tell
him I wasn't I was just like all right
buttoned me out too eh it was
we have been traveling with the
convenience tour and uh we're drivers we
get into the generally SUVs and drive
all over the place but
um the the leg of the tour this time was
like two dates in Toronto then we went
to Ottawa uh then we went to Grand
Rapids then we go here oh were you there
[ __ ] now I can't do the same jokes
[ __ ]
um
then we came here and then we go to
Montreal so for this entire leg up till
tonight and then tomorrow we fly to
Montreal we did not have an SUV we had
like a mom's minivan
um
and it was a lot of [ __ ] power on all
the freeways and [ __ ] like when you put
[ __ ] foot down and you're doing tops
58 like
you feel like I'm a [ __ ] road master
and [ __ ] but while we've been driving
around uh the kids Josh uh and Liv Are
Tour managers uh Josh has spent some
fair amount of time out kind of in the
Midwest and he was like oh my God if we
have time we gotta stop at Myers and I
was
and for a while I was like all right as
soon as I see one we'll stop and you
know we must have passed a bunch because
he's like are you ever going to stop at
Myers and I was like when I see a
[ __ ] Myers I'll stop I've not seen
one I see a my jerseys everywhere but I
don't [ __ ]
he's like that is it and I was like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] we stopped at Mars now the
kids were promising
um if Target and Walmart had a baby and
it was better than both of them put
together
so that's that was the high bar that
they placed on my jerseys and uh
we finally got to go today we had enough
time between Grand Rapids and here we
were like [ __ ] it let's go and so we
stopped at [ __ ] majors and
my God the kids were right it's like a
upscale classy baby of Target and
Walmart and [ __ ] but this is where they
[ __ ] sold me because Josh was like
I'm gonna go there I'm gonna get socks
man all day we're like socks socks socks
socks socks socks
because he's like my jersey has
everything he calls it Myers Myers says
everything and [ __ ] we got to Myers they
didn't have his [ __ ] socks at all
Myers let him the [ __ ] down where Target
would have [ __ ] helped him out and
[ __ ]
but you know he was like let's go out of
here we'll [ __ ] curse the dust on our
feet and leave this [ __ ] prophet's
land and [ __ ] but all of a sudden I saw
a pair of sweatpants that were furry on
the inside
[Applause]
and I had a little thing it's like
touched me and I was like just stoned
enough to be like I will
foreign
oh my God and it was [ __ ] heaven and
I was like I said to Josh and I was like
look I'll never say this again but put
your hand in my pants right now
and he fell to me because I was soft I
was like I'm going dick out in these
[ __ ] man
so [ __ ] I bought two pair and [ __ ]
they're going back to Jersey with me and
whatnot and this cold harsh winter
whenever I'm [ __ ] chilly and I'm dick
out in my Majors I'll think of you all
man
the tour continues kids there's 23 more
dates man we're doing this all the way
till like December 5th we added a show
in Boston uh we sold out a show in
Chicago so we added a show in Chicago we
sold out the show in Dallas so we added
a show in Dallas for everybody asking
um go to clerks3.movie and see what's
left as we're coming to your city and
don't forget movies on streaming right
now you can digitally watch clerks three
you can own it for heaven's sakes go to
Apple go to uh Amazon Prime go to
YouTube go to Voodoo anywhere they then
transactional streaming movies digital
video you can go watch it in the privacy
of your own home right now or come see
it on the convenience tour uh with me
this is everything I hoped it would be
kids Quick Stop is open for business
once again so go enjoy clerks three
tonight in the privacy of your own home
or come join me on the convenience tour
tickets at clerks3 dot movie I'll see
you at the movies kids
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]